police in Miami say they are getting
ready for the possibility of thousands
or even tens of thousands of protesters
outside the courthouse today when the
former president surrenders to U.S
Marshals Scott McFarland has more on the
security preparations in the city Scott
good morning they say that they are
ready
a Gaelic crowd is already formed but to
be clear it's really just media dozens
of these tencent cameras surround the
entirety of the front side of this
Downtown Courthouse complex if there are
Trump supporters or protesters here they
haven't shown themselves yet the former
president won't be seen walking into the
courthouse not through the front door
but through a private entrance with
secret service at his side
security preparations underway at the
federal courthouse in Miami ahead of
When Donald Trump is expected to be
booked and processed Tuesday so there
won't be a time when the secret service
is not with the former president former
U.S Secret Service deputy director A.T
Smith says Trump's security detail will
help escort the former president from
his Doral Resort to the Towering
courthouse in downtown Miami where
protesters will likely gather
multiple law enforcement officials tell
CBS News no credible specific threats
have been identified but that rhetoric
online is loud and has increased
significantly on both sides of the
political Arena the secret service has a
very robust intelligence section that
monitors this sort of thing as does the
FBI but it's the former president who
urged his own supporters to converge on
Miami today in a social media post we
are ready and uh
we're ready for it to be uh over and
gone Miami officials said they support
people Gathering to protest peacefully
and promised a heavy presence of local
and federal police outside we're
bringing enough resources to handle
crowd anywhere from five thousand to
fifty thousand that are in Miami defense
attorney Michelle suskauer says any
crowd isn't likely to get a glimpse of
trump so there's underground tunnels and
so we're not going to see that movement
we're not going to see a perp Walk we're
not going to see him being booked
the day began there were no police
barricades or bike racks outside this
Courthouse just the strips of yellow
police tape you see behind me the roads
nearby are open City police in the
streets and Gale federal agents here on
the courthouse steps
all right we are all we will all be
watching today thank you very much Scott